i'm not being can you legally come to
america
it's not like john fury or um
oh what's it called you know what that
was about
uh but about the uh the mafia the irish
muffins yeah
[ __ ] mod right but the tricky thing
is i actually understand
tommy's situation tommy's just been
roped into this exactly yeah and
you can't exactly cause that what
they're using him is for leverage right
like they're gonna bring him into the
[ __ ] office ask all about it and
tommy's just like i'm just [ __ ]
hanging around he's the last person you
would ask anything to wait really well
he's just a kid you know i mean he's
like a good looking lad but he's not
like he seems kind of sweet but he's not
gonna hack into nasa anytime soon you
know what i mean you guys don't have to
worry about national security with tommy
fury
what are you saying
he's not the smartest person you'll ever
meet in your life he's just a nice guy
you know he's a nice guy yeah but is is
he like a [ __ ] idiot is that what
that's what he said
was that what you were saying that's
right
there's a lot of theories there's only
one andrew taylor
i'm not be careful with these theories
no i like the views they're good people
no no i do i actually i felt bad for
tommy because i know that situation
where like he's given me two million bro
and he it was robbed from him just
because he knew a guy yeah
yeah and it would be hard for him if he
went in there and started answering
questions oh yeah yeah yeah that's not
worth two million
right like that's more stress for
everybody yeah i think his dad seen it
coming because dad did a video on social
beforehand being like we can't go to
america so it's got to be somewhere else
and i think he knew like oh [ __ ] yeah
because his dad's been
his dad can't get into america because
he gouged him on zio years ago really i
don't know if you know about big john
but big no big john's a character is his
dad a bad man his dad's a bad
[ __ ] talk to him for sure like i
he's a big guy like he's in his 50s and
you think you saw
not many 50 year old men who you'd
probably think twice about like in that
regard but he's up there big guy
his hands are like shovels he's more
intimidating than tyson fury get out of
here yeah because he's the guy who
created tyson like he's [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah he's just like
yeah and you gotta drink 30 diet cokes a
day to cope with what your dad did do
you
probably that's probably a scary
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah he he go it
says on the internet like he he gouged a
man's eye out over a debt
yeah i mean it makes sense he was a
journeyman boxer but i remember that
yeah like uh bayonetta and all that as
well but very talented actually
apparently i think that's probably why
he
put his sons into it and trained them up
you know yeah i mean tyson
tyson you know when tyson beat deontay
wilder they had a live camera on john in
this country because he couldn't get in
the mirror and he screams at the camera
and he goes that's what's come out of
these balls
like the ultimate pro dad comment in it
[ __ ] crazy there's a great
conversation that he has on the phone
with his dad oh yeah yeah that's almost
dude like it was super it was so
vulnerable and it was just a smile that
ever lived bro and i was i was too
strong for him dad i rolled him right
over yeah oh dude that's good it was so
cool i love that moment oh that's
amazing yeah he seemed like a little kid
this is the heavyweight champion in the
world he was 13 years old still still
still a child during that moment yeah
yeah yeah that's what happens when your
family loves you yeah
real talk
real talk dude liking hugs yo it was
honestly this is maybe a hot take about
tyson i think that tyson is the greatest
heavyweight ever i think it's the
greatest
which makes him probably i don't know
what's the bucks an expert saying though
what do you think i agree with that one
yeah yeah do you mean that in the sense
of heavy weight yeah if they all fall
great they all fought each other i don't
think anybody could be tested because of
right okay yeah i think the size the
skill
now the power earlier in his career he
didn't see this power and all of a
sudden like he's just [ __ ] i think uh
could give him some trouble he's so
small dude he's not
you six what six two no but when you
meet tyson although he's like
he he has weaknesses as well though like
he's he's big but if you so if you watch
anthony joshua versus alexander usic and
then right afterwards watch deontay
wilder versus tyson fury how slow
the fury wilder fight went
is alarming you realize the pace that
you success is light speed
so i'm not saying that yusic would beat
tyson but i think he'll give him a lot
of problems this is the fittest
heavyweight we've ever seen
no one is as fit as music no one not at
that size like he's six foot three as
well people think he's a small man he's
massive but what happens when tyson
starts leaning on him what happens when
he grabs him up and he leans on and you
got 300 whatever [ __ ] pounds he is i
don't i don't think he can get close
enough with how
with how fast yousek is to employ that
you can do that to a wilder who's gassed
after two rounds you six feet never stop
moving for 12 rounds he does four minute
rounds with 30 seconds rest in training
he is the fittest guy like i'm not
saying that i just think calling it over
and like fury's talking right now about
oh i'm the greatest i'm the greatest of
my generation you're having full aeg you
haven't fought you sick lennox lewis for
everyone look lennox is the other one
yeah right and lennox got caught by
haseem rockman i think that hurts the
legacy but like linux was the other one
i was like i don't really see anybody
beating him before that it was like and
again this isn't even my generation just
watching it like larry holmes was
[ __ ] unbelievable right i mean were
you know you're young i went back and
watched though like i interviewed
muhammad ali's grandson recently don't
know if you've seen who's boxing now
yeah yeah and um it's called like the
legacy continues yeah and uh i was
watching all muhammad ali videos and i
mean ali was unbelievable ali also at
like the peak weight is it fair to
compare someone would say
fury ain't going to be doing half the
[ __ ] he's doing right now like is the
innovator the original creator the
greatest or is the guy who watched that
and went oh let me put my you know what
i mean well i mean like when it comes to
boxing it's like who would win like
that's just what i guess if you're
saying that then fury's probably right
up there yeah who is the most
influential yeah like yeah nobody's
going to be completed
50 years of
science technology everything else
cause who knows what if muhammad ali was
raised now like he'd probably fight a
cruiserweight and he'd be like the most
dominant well he would have grown up a
lot bigger because he would have fought
a lot more and he would have been a huge
guy but
uh
i think that uh furies wins his best
wins against uh klitschko and deontay
they don't there's just not enough of a
legacy right now for me to go
like
when you look at what lennox did or what
muhammad all the wars muhammad ali like
to me being great is not just winning
all the time being great is like
overcoming adversity and yeah no one had
more than muhammad ali because when his
legs were gone he came back yeah the guy
was a punching bag at times and he still
overcome it i mean that's that's what
led to uh the last thing you want to
know about yourself as a boxer is you
have a great jaw and early in his career
he was never touched and later in his
career he found out that he could take a
hit
i mean that frasier fight where he gets
his jaw broken
and then
goes to decision
i mean that's insane have you seen mike
tyson's clip where they they say like
what do you think of muhammad ali
compared to you
tyson starts crying he's like
he's willing to die for this and i'm not
i'm not i'm not him that was when i was
like
yeah no ali is a different dude
my pops was a journalist and he would uh
get to interview ali a lot and he has
like
he's like footage of him like shadow
boxing with muhammad ali it's like the
craziest thing ever wow and uh and ali
is a joke what do you box oranges
and uh but he asked ali before frasier
he goes dude not a freighter yeah lee
before foreman he goes how are you gonna
beat this guy like this this if if
people don't remember like when foreman
fought frasier which was before ali he
hit fragile with an uppercut that lifted
him off the canvas
like the power was different
like nobody had seen this before right
so
the idea that ali was going to come back
and like fight him and was like what
were you crazy like he was how are you
going to beat this guy and he goes um
he goes
ali goes here's the thing like
you you do what you do all these people
you do what you do you know how to be a
journalist scientists know how to be
scientists like i know how to box
i'm just going to get it done it's
simple as that like there's not even a
question in my mind i'm gonna beat this
guy and you're stupid to think that i'm
not gonna beat him like the supreme
confidence everybody throws [ __ ] and
he goes out there and he [ __ ] gets it
done and that wasn't the original
strategy
the robodope was not the original
strategy but he just found a [ __ ] way
did you hear fullman's interview on my
phone and was like i hit him and it was
just like
i never expected yeah he said i felt
like i was in there with someone on a
sort of like supernatural yeah like
like and i think that the power of the
mind is like you really say that in
fighting sometimes like i think
realistically tyson fury probably
shouldn't have won a few of his fights
against the underworld are they like he
said when he got nailed to the floor
like when when he got dropped twice in
that round how many fighters get back up
and then knock this guy out but he's got
it up there where the i think religion
helps fighters as well
well this idea that like yeah like like
that god is with you in there and all of
that like i think muhammad ali had that
and one of my mates who was a really
high level amateur boxing box for great
britain and that he was like i wish i
was religious because it seems to
[ __ ] motivate the hell out of these
[ __ ]
he's in there as a [ __ ] atheist
thinking
i wish god was with me right now yeah
cause like if they die in the ring they
get to go to heaven
so there's nothing to risk yet
it's a huge advantage it removes the
urgency of survival
maybe they should make suicide bombers
boxers yes just saying whoa that's a
great idea that'd be a good promotion
that'd be crazy there we go i've been
saying i want a pakistani champion we
could really just
get this done luca blows himself up